aside from the uh the win from due of
the year the more impressive thing to me
is that you're starting a tradition of
closing the acm awards
so i feel like that's something that's
notable and important uh thoughts about
going out there to close this event when
the event's all done and you have to
like knock it out of the park thoughts
about that
well i mean i think the expectations are
really high in that moment but we knew
with with brittany and her vocal ability
and just her stage presence and we liked
the arrangement that we came up with and
it was something that i
genuinely just wanted to play i was like
this is going to be exciting and fun to
play we also knew there was going to be
confetti cannons at some point i've
never experienced that
um but i felt really excited about the
whole thing i thought tonight just us
aside i thought the whole night went
very well and it was just the energy in
the room was fun it was an interesting
moment when you said they pulled your
single last week
and then you went just homework right
how much when does this put in your sale
because i feel like
there are a lot of maybe jaded people
that don't realize these awards matter
yeah well yeah absolutely yeah
can you talk about that yeah they
absolutely 100 do matter um you know
that i could speak for my brother here
to say that that comment was made ingest
it's not completely wrong
but that was made more like in fun and
in the moment and some people on radio
have been really really great to us not
entirely and that's okay so we kind of
keep pushing and trying to persevere and
what has kept us going for i'd say the
past eight years are these i mean it is
kept wind in our sails i mean not only
what it does in terms of you know the
fan base and and the notoriety but what
it does for us is people that are
constantly fighting what we feel like is
an uphill battle even when we do win but
it puts the wind in our manager sales
and our label sales are banned in our
crew i mean it's it's a lot bigger than
people i think actually know these
things really truly do keep you going
yeah and i i mean i'll explain all that
too and say that you know i mentioned
this recently in an article of just with
us feeling like we're underdogs the
whole time and i think that's part of it
is that we don't get necessarily a lot
of the love at some of the other artists
who are on radio and and i'm not
necessarily criticizing any anyone
specifically for that but it's just a
fact and
um to be there tonight i guess some
people are saying that i guess some
people are upset that i said that like i
said a true statement i don't know i or
a single literally got pulled last week
and we just wanted a word if you're
upset about that then maybe you're part
of the problem but
uh beyond that i um just think that we
um do feel that way and in these moments
we get to like get an award and get back
up on stage and have that moment it's
like okay it does feel it it does it
gives us that energy to keep keep
pushing forward
and the follow-up it's a two-prong
follow-up
half of my follow is
it creates opportunities and i wish you
guys would talk about some of the
opportunities these awards
create but it also says there's more
than one path up the mountain you all
have a very successful career
and you have enough radio success that
people like rock out to you i'm in
florida people seem like guilty of a
damn good time t-shirt and i get this
so you know
i wish you could elaborate on that a
little bit no you're absolutely right
the fact that you said there is more
than one way up the mountain is exactly
it i feel like as days go on as we
progress and things evolve within the
industry there are a lot more avenues
and to have a lot of success at radio is
really amazing and it has done a lot of
people a lot of very a lot of good and
it's changed their lives but there are
more than one ways to do it i mean at
one point there wasn't and now there are
a lot of ways
i mean we see
people getting successes through winning
awards in our in our beautiful industry
lifting us up and other people building
their careers just via the internet with
no record deals at all even so there are
a lot of opportunities for a lot of
artists and in my own humble opinion i
think that is
amazing i think that's incredible and i
think it's a uh i think it's a beacon
for us in the music industry in my
opinion and his opinion as well
all right we've got another question
here in person
hey guys it's ricky with celebrity page
tv
i'm so good and i have to congratulate
you both i mean getting duel of the year
honestly it's not a surprise but it's so
well deserved and i just have to ask you
both i mean just seeing where you guys
started to where you are now i feel like
you're inspiring so many people out
there fans young and old and especially
tj in the community that are finally
feeling comfortable seeing someone like
you getting these awards putting these
songs out there so when you see people
are just really connecting to you guys
and finally seeing feeling seen in the
country music space how humbling and
important do you think that is i think
it's important in a lot of ways you know
i think um
you know i think originally i didn't
really think that i i didn't really
understand the gravity of the moment
when i would come out and share that
with everyone uh how necessary that
would help so many other people and that
has been such a beautiful thing to
experience but i also will say that you
know i think
country for the longest time has prided
itself on on just being as as harlan
howard said three chords in the truth
and
i think that now that it is a place
where you can live your own truth as
cliche as that is
i i think it is that way and and
and i think to end the
award show with
um so much different representation my
brother and me and then brittany up
there that was really cool and it felt
to me very natural and not forced and it
was just a
a really uh great moment a great musical
moment and um i think it's great for
country music in so many ways but i
think it's it's ultimately i think
really the best for the country music
fans out there that haven't necessarily
felt they've loved country music but
haven't felt like they've had a home for
them for so many years and
we've seen it at our shows where they're
showing up and we get to look out the
crowd and have people that feel
uh proud and comfortable being
themselves whatever that is um
is is more rewarding than anything you
mentioned you know just kind of still
feeling a bit like outsiders in this
industry i want to know you know
managing that how much is it helpful to
have the support of your loved ones
through all this not just each other but
you know your significant others your
family to just kind of manage everything
through this
um you know i like that question because
i think ultimately what i mean what do
we want in this life it's just really to
be loved you know and i think
we have that and so at the end of the
day everything else is really kind of a
cherry on top and i think it gives us a
lot of comfort just being ourselves and
doing things that maybe be
artistically on the edge
because at the end of the day we and it
sounds really cheesy but we really do
have what we need and want and will ever
want and so there's really not much to
lose at that point it's really just
about trying to make a difference in
what whatever that looks like
and
so i think that's that is truly the
biggest the biggest thing